OUR PART, IT'S NOT GOING TO
CHANGE AT ALL THE SUPPORT THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO GIVE
UKRAINE AS THEY PROSECUTE THIS
WAR.
>> LET'S TURN TOWARD THE
PRESIDENT'S TRIP TO THE MIDDLE
EAST AND SPECIFICALLY ON SAUDI
ARABIA, I WANT YOU TO LISTEN TO
WHAT SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS SAID
ABOUT THE DECISION TO VISIT THE
SAUDI KINGDOM.
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
YOU HAVE THE LEADER OF THAT
COUNTRY WHO WAS INVOLVED IN THE
MURDER OF A "WASHINGTON POST"
JOURNALIST.
I DON'T THINK THAT THAT TYPE OF
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE REWARDED
WITH A VISIT BY THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
>> WHAT'S YOUR REACTION AND
RESPONSE TO THAT?
>> THE PRESIDENT BELIEVES IF
YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE VALUES OF
HUMAN RIGHTS THE CENTER OF YOUR
FOREIGN POLICY, WHICH HE DOES,
THE BEST WAY TO ADVANCE THOSE
RIGHTS, ADVANCE THOSE VALUES,
PROTECT AND PROMOTE THEM IS TO
ACTUALLY GO OVERSEAS, AND TALK
TO FOREIGN LEADERS AND BE DIRECT
AND CANDID AND IN THE ROOM.
YOU CAN'T SAY THAT VALUES MATTER
AND THEN STAY AT HOME AND REFUSE
TO TALK TO PEOPLE OR REFUSE TO
MAKE THE CASE.
THE PRESIDENT FELT IT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT IN EVERY STOP ON
THIS TRIP, VICTOR, HE'D TALK
ABOUT HUMAN RIGHTS, AND HE DID.
THESE ARE NOT EASY CONVERSATIONS
TO HAVE, BUT THEY'RE IMPORTANT
TO HAVE IF YOU'RE GOING TO TRY
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE OVERSEAS.
>> DID THE PRESIDENT DIRECTLY
BRING UP THE AMERICANS WHO WERE
HELD IN SAUDI ARABIA WHO EITHER
IMPRISONED OR NOT ALLOWED TO
LEAVE THE COUNTRY.
>> IT ALL STOPS, THE PRESIDENT
HAS TALKED OBJECT WRONGFULLY
DETAINED AMERICANS, AND THAT WAS
NO DIFFERENT ON THIS TRIP AT
ALL.
>> SO HE DID MENTION TO THE
CROWN PRINCE THOSE AMERICANS WHO
WERE BEING HELD AND NOT ALLOWED
TO LEAVE SAUDI ARABIA.
>> HE TALKED TO THE PRINCE ABOUT
A RANGE OF OUR HUMAN RIGHTS
CONCERNS, INCLUDING AMERICANS
THAT ARE WRONGFULLY DETAINED.
>> OKAY.
LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THE FIST
BUMP, WHICH "THE WASHINGTON
POST," OBVIOUSLY JAMAL KHASHOGGI
WAS A COLUMNIST THERE, AND THEY
SAID IT WAS SHAMEFUL.
CONGRESSMAN SCHIFF, A DEMOCRAT
SAID A FIST BUMP WORTH A
THOUSAND WORDS.
ONCE THE WHITE HOUSE DECIDED
THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS GOING, OF
COURSE THERE WOULD BE A PUBLIC
GREETING OF SOME SORT, THE CROWN
PRINCE WOULD BE AT THE MEETING.
WHAT WAS CONSIDERED?
WERE ALTERNATIVES CONSIDERED OR
WERE YOU PREPARED FOR THAT
MOMENT AND YOU'RE OKAY WITH WHAT
YOU SAW?
>> THROUGHOUT THIS TRIP, VICTOR,
AS THE PRESIDENT GREETED LEADERS
FROM ALL AROUND THE REGION, HE
GREETED THEM ALL IN DIFFERENT
WAYS, BASED ON HIS PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEM.
SOME SHOOK HANDS, SOME HE DID A
FIST BUMP.
IT WASN'T UNUSUAL FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO MIX IT UP BASED ON
WHO HE WAS MEETING AT THE
MOMENT.
HE WAS MUCH LESS WORRIED ABOUT
THE GREETINGS THAN THE MEETINGS,
AND THE MEETINGS IN SAUDI ARABIA
WERE IMPORTANT TO HAVE, AND THEY
PRODUCED RESULTS, AND THEY WILL
PROBABLY PRODUCE RESULTS GOING
FORWARD IN THE FUTURE THAT ARE
IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
.
THE PRESIDENT WENT ON THIS TRIP
BECAUSE IT WAS IN THE NATIONAL
INTEREST THAT HE DO IT, WHETHER
IT WAS ISRAEL OR BETHLEHEM WITH
PRESIDENT ABBAS AND THE
PALESTINIAN AUTHORITY AND
CERTAINLY IN SAUDI ARABIA,
MEETING WITH NINE HEADS OF STATE
ACROSS THE GULF COOPERATION
COUNCIL.
THERE WAS AN AWFUL LOT ON THE
AGENDA THAT WE WEREN'T TALKING
ABOUT AND THE PRESIDENT FEELS
THOSE ITEMS ON THE AGENDA, THEY
WERE IMPORTANT, THE MEETINGS
WERE MUCH MORE IMPORTANT THAN
THE GREETINGS.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT, JOHN, BUT
THE GREETING IS IMPORTANT.
THE OPTICS ARE IMPORTANT.
YOU AND I HAD THIS CONVERSATION
WHEN YOU WERE WORKING HERE AT
CNN IN 2018, AND DONALD TRUMP
WAS MEETING WITH KIM -- KIM JONG
UN OF NORTH KOREA, AND WE TALKED
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
OPTICS AND HOW THOSE PICTURES
SPEAK WITHOUT PEOPLE GOING TO
READ THE COLUMNS ON WHAT WAS
ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISHED OR NOT.
SO DOES THIS OFFER THE SAUDIS
THE DEGREE OF POTENTIALLY RA
HABILITATION, THE IMAGE ALONE
THEY HOPED FOR.
>> THERE WAS NO WAY THE
PRESIDENT WASN'T GOING TO GREET
THE CROWN PRINCE WHO HE WAS POST
HOSTING ON BEHALF OF THE KING,
AND PART OF THE BILATERAL
DISCUSSIONS FRIDAY NIGHT IN
SAUDI ARABIA.
THERE WAS NO WAY THEY WEREN'T
GOING TO MEET ONE ANOTHER AND
HAVE A GREETING.
IT WAS A ONE-SECOND FIST BUMP,
THE PRESIDENT MOVED ON AND WAS
MUCH MORE FOCUSED ON WHAT THE
AGENDA WAS IN THE ROOM.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S MOVE ON AND TALK ABOUT
RUSSIA AND IRAN.
PRESIDENT PUTIN LEAVING RUSSIA I
BELIEVE FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE
THE INVASION.
HE'S GOING TO BE IN TEHERAN.
AND WE KNOW THAT THE WHITE HOUSE
SAYS THAT RUSSIAN OFFICIALS WERE
THERE LOOKING AT SOME POTENTIAL
WEAPON-CAPABLE DRONES THERE,
YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT IRAN'S
ASSISTANCE AND THIS MEETING
THAT'S COMING UP?
>> YEAH, OBVIOUSLY IT'S
CONCERNING, AND WE WOULDN'T HAVE
PUT THE INFORMATION OUT IN THE
PUBLIC IF WE DIDN'T BELIEVE THAT
IT'S CONCERNING, THAT MR. PUTIN
COULD BE ARMING HIMSELF WITH
SOME ADVANCED DRONE CAPABILITIES
THAT HAVE ACTUAL KINETIC
EFFECTS.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY CAN LAUNCH
WEAPONS AND MISSILES AND ROCKETS
FROM THESE DRONES AND FURTHER
PROSECUTE THE WAR IN UKRAINE,
FURTHER CAUSE DEATH AND
DESTRUCTION INSIDE UKRAINE, SO
OF COURSE IT'S CONCERNING.
BUT, VICTOR, IT'S INDICATIVE OF
A COUPLE OF THINGS.
NUMBER ONE, HOW MUCH MORE
ISOLATED FROM THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY IRAN IS BECOMING.
THERE'S A DEAL ON THE TABLE TO
DEAL WITH THEIR NUCLEAR
AMBITIONS, THEY NEED TO TAKE
THAT DEAL.
THIS IS JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
HOW THEY ARE CONTINUING TO
ISOLATE THEMSELVES FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY AND,
TWO, IT'S INDICATIVE OF MR.
PUTIN'S EFFORTS TO TRY TO
REPLENISH HIS WEAPONS AND
CAPABILITIES, AND THE TROUBLE
THAT HE'S HAVING, DUE TO THE
SANCTIONS, DUE TO THE EXPORT
CONTROLS.
HE'S HAVING TROUBLE WITH MICRO
ELECTRONICS IN REPLENISHING HIS
PRECISION GUIDE AMMUNITIONS, AND
HIS DONE CAPABILITY.
YOU HAVE OVER THE COURSE OF THE
LAST WEEKEND, AN INTERESTING
SPLIT SCREEN.
YOU'VE GOT PRESIDENT BIDEN IN
THE MIDDLE EAST WORKING FOR A
BETTER INTEGRATED, MORE STABLE,
MORE SECURE MIDDLE EAST WITH
MULTIPLE HEADS OF STATES ACROSS